[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans sa hotte caddie
avec notre invité ce matin yanis rosa
mon bonjour moi j'aimerais tant que oui
aujourd'hui
bonjour à tous il ya des travaux de
l'association lui mina et sa web tv un
luminaire tv télévision sur le net
alors on sait que vous organisez entre
autres avec l'association luminale est
pris lui mina trophée de la jeunesse
inquiets une mise à l'honneur donc des
jeunes qui ont réussi et ont valeur
d'exemple pour les autres jeunes de la
société martiniquaise mais la liane
heathrow amont vous êtes venu nous
parler d'un sujet difficile épineux
épineux très sensible douloureux même
évidemment parce que l'association lui
mina va réaliser un documentaire avec le
réalisateur j mc anor un documentaire
qui traite de la douloureuse question du
suicide chez les jeunes de moins de 30
ans dites nous quelle est la genèse de
cette initiative
comment avez-vous pensé à traiter de ce
sujet je le répète douloureux alors je
met le pied dans on entre là d'entrée
moi à titre personnel à 31 ans j'ai déjà
connu trois suicides de jeunes et parmi
mes mes camarades il n'ya ya notamment
des gens qui a perdu des jeunes des
garçons qui sont partis très tôt juste
avant 30 ans qui sont partis sur
effectivement des situations qu'elle
jugeait à ce moment là très douloureuse
et qui ne pouvait pas considérer en tout
cas qui ne pouvait plus rester sur le
terrain et donc on a donc travaillé avec
un réalisateur qui a gagné le festival
prix de court il y a deux ans dans la
partie publique puisqu'il s'agit de gym
un canot qui avait fait un documentaire
sur les femmes battues avec petit bout
de soleil qui avait rencontré d'ailleurs
vu succès qu'elle même et y est relayée
par la presse nationale et notamment
marlène chape ya je crois et donc du
coup on s'est dit si nous mettions nos
écrans combien pouvoir traiter de cette
question ça pourrait être pas mal et
c'est l'objectif de ce documentaire
d'autant que vous dit que c'est un sujet
tabou et gretel kiki qui est très peu
abordée quand même des difficultés à
être abordée c'est très douloureux au
sein de notre société
alors dis j'en ai accompagnés par des
personnes qui sont en fait bien de
sainte-rose de l'association sos crise
et monsieur j m donc on parle pas à
l'abordage sans sens sans balises
mais c'est surtout un sujet tabou tout
simplement parce qu'en réalité le ms a
demandé aux agences de santé nationales
d'éviter un peu de communiquer sur ces
chiffres parce qu'ils ont peur c'est
vraiment de l'effet domino puisqu'on ce
qu'on constate avec les tueries dans par
exemple les university aux états unis
c'est que quand vous avez passé une vie
une existence dans le silence l'anonymat
parfois certains voudraient que leur vie
soit belle ou tout simplement avec leur
mort soit mémorable
mais sitôt sujet un peu tabou
effectivement parce qu'on a vraiment
peur de l'effet domino que certains se
suicider que d'autres le suivent
sauf qu'il ya eu un avant et un après
notamment avec l'arrivée de netflix est
une série qui s'appelle foutiyou
noailles qui traite une fille d'une
jeune fille en fait qui a décidé de
romance et son suicide
donc c'est un film qui a fait scandale
aux etats unis dans le monde entier et
en fait je pousse son décès elle a
laissé 13 cassettes sur lesquels elle
explique un peu pourquoi s'est suicidé
il ya un an constatée notamment aux
états unis dans les pays de l' ocde une
augmentation du taux de suicide de 30%
au niveau de cette population là qui
fait que pour la saison 2 ils ont dû
accompagner leur lot film de messages de
prévention pour dire si vous avez un
souci n'hésitez pas à nous dire de
revenir et beaucoup de débats et
notamment des questions sur l'ascension
parce qu'à un moment voyez son suicide
et donc du coup tout ça a changé un peu
les paradigmes et on se dit qu'il est
peut-être temps de parler ce sujet tabou
qui notamment prison un igloo dont on ne
parle plus alors précisément vous
parliez de chiffres aux états unis ici
j'ai vu que vous avez mis en annexe d'un
dossier de présentation des extraits de
journaux
alors je sais pas de quand date celui là
mais il y en a un qui signale qu'on
enregistre un suicide par semaine en
moyenne
en martinique c'est toujours le cas à
l'heure on parlait ce oui ça n'a pas dû
baisser et forcément peut-être pas tant
augmenté que ça mais voilà je ne suis
pas sûr que ça ait changé mais pour
avoir des chiffres c'est très difficile
sincèrement si c'est compliqué parce que
même si même souvent trentaine j'avais
pu voir un sujet d'un taux de journal et
même des chiffres qu'ils ont donné ce
sont des chiffres à partir des rouleaux
de 40 ans mais on a ici je tenir quand
même ces jeux comme une question tabou
sur cette question là où et qui mérite
qu'on en parle bien sûr et puis il ya
des familles qui ne souhaitent pas
souvent que exactement sache que
justement il y a eu sa et 2
que c'est des statistiques qui sont un
peu biaisé de ce point de vue là comment
dirais-je le format on va parler du
scénario de ce que disent la sarre à
contes mais vous avez choisi de faire un
documentaire de 52 minutes 1 d'une durée
de 52 minutes pour être diffusée sur
enfin une diffusion multi supports
exactement ça en fait l'idée séculaire
en dépend at il aidé à ben de 40 minutes
qui d'abord une partie film et à près de
deux minutes qui ne partit 12 à 22
minutes qu'ils aient une vente y ait un
peu plus documenté dirons nous nous
avons des témoignages de personnes qui
ont fait des tentatives des personnes
qui ont perdu un proche de leur famille
des personnes qui regrette dix
encadrants qui n'ont pas vu les choses
venir
et toutes ces personnes dans votre thé
moines en se demandant ce qu'ils
auraient pu faire
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas vu et comment
on aurait pu améliorer certaines choses
donc donc il ya une vocation aussi de
prévention à travers notamment de la
prévention sur le film séduit menteuse
notamment dans la prévention déjà
d'abord par rapport au format 52 minutes
qui puisse être que diffuser dans une
classe on attend également que les si la
situation sanitaire soit favorable pour
pouvoir avoir vraiment issus de deux
circuits à l'atrium ans quand madonna
pour pouvoir et une diffusion prévue sur
notre antenne et bien sûr sur les bien
sûr unique la première alors nous sommes
en personnages en ce moment il y décède
avant une diffusion sur martin promis en
septembre
septembre c'est aussi la semaine
mondiale de prévention du suicide qui
cette année consacrée aux jeunes à
thématique des jeunes et donc
et donc voilà alors vous avez parlé on a
évoqué donc le réalisateur un gym à
cahors donc lauréat du festival prix de
court 2019
alors vous vous êtes chef de projet
yanis trop hamon et puis il y as parmi
les actrices
l'une des actrices principales une
chanteuse bien connue
princess lover ses choix voilà vous
alors je peux vous donner tous les
castings donc en fait nous avons pu nous
être sûrs qu'ils jouaient leur rôle de
la maman nous avons vous connaissez is
it ont fait trois personnes que vous
connaissez ici très bien en la personne
de patricia tine n'est ce pas dû me
stéphanie interdit avait fabrice
théodose vous avez dj qui lorsqu'elle
est reconnu sur cette cible jeune rani
charles qui joue le rôle de la jeune un
peu tourmenté stéphane salomon dj killer
j'ai déjà dit en fait nous avons quand
même pas mal de personnes bobby
production d'ailleurs qui qui qui se
sont mis en fait tous ensemble pour
pouvoir y changer cette discussion là le
c'est ça qui est bien aussi un travail
collectif français souverains qu'incarne
le rôle d'une maman qui elle même est
tellement happé par la société tellement
appuyé par le monde par sont pourtant
pas toutes choses qui parfois ne voit
pas forcément des traces de son enfant
ou n'a pas le temps on n'y arrive pas et
dans le film sans spolier
au bout d'un moment elle comprend que
non et que ça son enfance et sa priorité
et donc du coup on envoie tout valser
pour enfants ici aussi c'est raide et
acteur qu'on veut mettre en avant et
quoi de mieux vous ceux qui la
connaissent que qu'on cesse l'ouvrir
pour pouvoir avoir des traits de
caractère un peu exubérant dirons nous
et justement le temps de 2,2 de
remercier de souligner le travail
formidable d'une jeune parce que le
scénario est écrit par les jeunes qui a
fait des études de scénaristes en la
personne de caroline c'est l'instinct on
travaille qu'avec des jeunes non c'est
bon de le préciser qu'ils sortent de
l'école et qui nous font défaut non pas
forcément
ni le cv ni les contacts etc dr les
célestins qui doit avoir à peine 20 ans
mégane 2 juin détiennent william hague
sur marin voilà ils se reconnaîtront cd
que j'ai un doute qui se reconnaîtront
et qui travaillent autour de cette
thématique là coup la moyenne d'âge est
de alex écosse je suis le plus vieux moi
alors un documentaire donc kiki van chi
qui sera entre témoignages de survivants
de tentatives de suicide témoignages de
familles de proches de décéder deux
spécialistes du milieu de la santé et
puis quelques reconstitutions aussi de
hennezel scène donc il y aura deux
centres réalité réalisme et fiction on
va dire mais justement la partie fictive
sans trop dévoiler raconte donc
l'histoire de mélanie une jeune lycéenne
exactement mélanie qu'écornée parlera ni
charles qui une jeune une jeune fille
qui fait également des vidéos sur
internet qui emploie au doute
comme beaucoup de jeunes de son âge qui
a entre 16 et 18 ans et qui se retrouve
face à des situations où elle considère
que le suicide est sa seule voix donc je
ne vais pas spoiler estonie il du coup
elle se demande sincèrement s'il
faudrait pas que depuis ce martyr mais
en réalité la vie lui montre que c'est
pas ça et donc du coup c'est pour ça que
le film s'appelle j'avais toute la vie
devant moi encore j'ai toute la vie
devant moi puisque du couvent en réalité
que les souffrances qu'elle a 18 ans ne
sont pas celles qu'elle vivra dans 10
ans ou que voilà au tour grâce à la
forge et pouvoir être la femme qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
on ajoutera parmi les éléments que vous
apportez justement pour expliquer la
nécessité l'utilité de de cette action
de réaliser un tel documentaire autour
de ce sujet tellement tellement sensible
le suicide des jeunes dans 90% des cas
une personne qui a des idées suicidaires
ou qui passent à l'acte souffrent d'une
dépression
donc effectivement il faut être attentif
à la façon dont le caractère de ces
jeunes évoluent on va parler des moyens
parce que c'est aussi important le nerf
de la guerre mais juste quelques mots
donc le tournage il a déjà débuté où il
va débuter ce dimanche
non il y en a qui est programmée ce
week-end exacte du côté de saint joseph
mais ça y est les chars le mériter il y
en a déjà tourné j'ai enclenché on a
déjà donné plusieurs scènes et on a
effectivement les personnes qui nous ont
envers eux leur site pour pouvoir
tourner ces scènes là il fait team ont
une belle scène qui se trouvera
également dans son lycée d'adoption au
collège de saint joseph ce dimanche
alors ça va concerner tout le monde
évidemment j'aurais tellement destiné
aux jeunes en gros entre 14 et une
trentaine d'années un donc le choix de
la fiction dit vous aura pour but de
retenir l'attention et sensibiliser
particulièrement cette catégorie là du
public mais c'est tout public
donc pour ce sujet encore tabou mais on
l'a bien vu bien présents sur l'île de
la martinique les moyens à leur rend
bien
vous avez le budget vous avez bouclé le
budget j'ai vu vous avez adressé une
demande des deux subventions
enfin c'était un prêt à la ctm avec un
courrier adressé directement au
président du conseil exécutif
vous avez une réponse vous aurez le
soutien de la ctm oralement
effectivement la 7e nos soutiens on
attend toujours la validation écrite de
cette décision mais important de
souligner qu'on a l'entière un lunch et
soutien de la caisse d'allocations
familiales pour sa bourse sa branche
jeunesse qui nous soutient dessus ainsi
que la djs il est sous cette thématique
d'accord la jet de convient à peu près
élu pour ça on est en gros une
fourchette un goût franchement on dit on
est à moins de 50000 euros et donc du
coup on voit donc on a un bon premier 50
minéraux et la ville de fort-de-france
également nous accompagnent cette
thématique puisque son son maire y est
aussi enseignant dans 12 et une
thématique qui la touche tout
particulièrement
merci yanis rosa monde d'être venu nous
parler donc de ce tournage du
documentaire j'avais la vie devant moi
donc par l'association lumine à vous
êtes le chef de projet voilà et donc ce
documentaire en principe devrait être
diffusé sur plusieurs supports et sur
notre antenne télé en septembre prochain
voilà on en reparlera merci bon courage
et inciter à tous bonne journée tout de
même